creo que ya hemos hecho bastantes vídeos
hablando del producto punto de dos
vectores y nosotros ya dominamos
perfectamente el producto punto sobre
entonces de pensar en lo que definimos
como el producto cruz y es que el
producto cruz es también otra forma de
multiplicar dos vectores recuerdas que
hace tiempo te había dicho que había
varias formas de multiplicar dos
vectores pues el producto cruz es la
segunda y seguramente ya has visto cómo
obtener el producto cruz porque es algo
muy intuitivo y que tarde o temprano
llegaste a ver el producto punto lo que
nosotros habíamos visto es un producto
que estaba definido para dos vectores en
rn en cualquier dimensión tomábamos dos
vectores a ive y para estos dos vectores
el producto punto estaba bien definido
sin embargo ahora que pensamos en el
producto cruz tenemos una limitante el
producto cruz solamente está definido
para vectores en r3 solamente estamos
viviendo en r3 ahora otra de las
diferencias importantes es que el
producto punto cuando nosotros lo
realizamos nos daba un escalar recuerda
el producto punto nos daba una escalar
un numerito un número real mientras que
si nosotros pensamos en el producto cruz
este no nos va a dar de resultado una
escalar nos va a dar de resultado un
vector y bueno cual es el vector
resultante del producto cruz pues vamos
a ver vamos a definirlo y seguramente te
vas a hacer memoria y te vas a acordar
que esto ya alguna vez lo habías visto
entonces el producto cruz de dos
vectores voy a tomarme dos vectores aquí
en r3 a base de mi vector cuyas
componentes va a ser a 1 a 2 y a 3 y
ahora me voy a tomar otro vector otro
vector de director d también está en r 3
y sus componentes van a ser la b1 b2 y
b3 tenemos tres componentes porque
estamos en r3 perfecto y ahora quienes a
cruz be o dicho de otra manera quien va
a ser a producto cruz con b bueno pues
vamos a definirlo y eso tiene que ver
bastante con como hacíamos operaciones
con matrices y determinantes y bueno de
hecho creo que no hemos definido ni
matriz ni determinantes pero alguna vez
cuando hablamos acerca de ecuaciones
lineales o método de desarrollos que se
yo fíjate bien tenemos que tener tres
componentes porque esto también va a
vivir en r3 tres componentes la primera
componente la vamos a sacar tachando
estos dos y fijándonos solamente en a 2
b 2 a 3 cp 3 y para obtener esto vamos a
ser a 2 x b 3 ya esto le vamos a quitar
a 3 x de dos esto es muy importante a 2
b 3 menos a 3 b 2 así es como vamos a
definir la primer componente de a cruz b
ojo quitamos las primeras componentes y
sacamos el determinante por así decirlo
de la matriz a 2 b 2 a 3 b 3 y no te
compliques la vida tal vez no sea tan
difícil como lo piensas ahorita siempre
sencillamente todos para abajo menos
todos para arriba en este primer
componente a 2 x b 3 bajamos en diagonal
ya eso le vamos a quitar a 3 x de 2 y
nos olvidamos de las primeras
componentes déjenme escribirlo a 2 b 3
ya esto le voy a quitar a 3 x de 2 menos
a 3 x b 2 y ojo el signo de enmedio
siempre es menos siempre es negativo
ahora como sacó la segunda componente de
la cruz b bueno pues eso también sea muy
fácil lo único que hay que hacer es
eliminar estas dos que tenemos aquí y
seguramente vamos a decir ah pues es a 1
por b 3 menos a 3 por ver 1 pero ojo
solamente en esta ocasión cuando te
hablamos de la segunda componente del
producto cruz lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente vamos a voltear el orden
primero van a ser para arriba menos los
de abajo es decir a 3 por ver uno menos
a uno por b 3 volteamos el orden de los
sumandos va a ser a 3 por b 1 primero
todos para arriba y después menos todos
para abajo a 3 por b 1 y esto le vamos a
quitar la multiplicación de la diagonal
hacia abajo es decir menos a 1 por b 3 y
este es el caso especial del producto
cruz recuerda que la segunda componente
del producto cruz pasa algo extraño en
la componente 3 pues nos olvidamos por
un rato o cancelamos la tercera
componente de estos dos vectores y me va
a quedar a 1
v2 normal todos para abajo - todos para
arriba ya esto le voy a quitar menos a 2
por 21 a 2 por de 1 y así está definido
a cruz ve el producto cruz de dos
vectores y bueno este producto cruz
tiene propiedades muy importante es que
justo ahorita vamos a ver pero antes de
eso quiero que vayamos practicando la
idea del producto cruz y para esto voy a
utilizar un ejemplo y van a ver que no
es tan difícil aprenderse todo esto que
tenemos aquí arriba voy a tomarme el
vector 1 menos 71 ya éste le voy a
calcular su producto cruz con el vector
5 2 4 y que nos va a quedar bueno
recuerda que el producto cruz en su
primer componente lo que tenemos que
hacer es ignorar otras veces como que
olvidarnos un poco de las dos primeras
componentes y solamente fijarnos en los
componentes dos y tres de mis vectores
anteriores y me va a quedar menos 7 por
4 menos 7 por 4 déjeme escribirlo x
menos 7 por 4 ya esto hay que quitarle
menos uno por dos menos uno por dos y
después llegamos en la segunda
componente la importantísima segunda
componente es
de bizarra porque recuerden que
realmente lo que tenemos que hacer la
segunda componente además de olvidarnos
por un rato de las segundas componentes
anteriores es multiplicar las diagonales
al revés es decir vamos a multiplicar 1
por 5 ya esto le vamos a quitar 1 x 4 y
después llegamos la componente número 3
y la componente número 3 es normal
primero para abajo y después para arriba
y nos olvidamos por un rato de las
terceras componentes de los dos vectores
anteriores y simple y sencillamente me
queda 1 por 2 y después a esto hay que
quitarle menos 7 por 5 dejen ponerle un
paréntesis menos 7 que multiplica a 5
déjame ver si lo estoy poniendo bien es
este por este y es menos 7 por 5 y bueno
solamente que es las correspondientes
cuentas lo que tenemos aquí vamos a ver
menos 7 por 4 es 28 menos 7 por 4 28
menos 2 me va a quedar atrás ejemplo
aquí esto es menos 28 y después menos 2
y de resultado me queda menos 30 ó 30 es
negativo
después tengo 1 por 5 es uno menos 4a
pues estos 1
11 es 1 por 55 menos 4 es uno positivo y
después para finalizar tengo 1 por 2 que
es 2 - por menos me da más
entonces me queda 2 más 35 o 2 - menos
35 lo cual me da 37 perfecto ya tengo mi
lector resultado de cruz ven y
seguramente te estás preguntando bueno
hay para que ver el producto cruz de dos
vectores en r3 qué chiste tiene este
producto cruz y es que el vector cruz
cumple una propiedad muy importante y es
que el vector resultante del producto
cruz ya sea el numérico o el abstracto
cumple que es un vector ortogonal ojo es
un vector ortogonal tanto a como a b es
decir es un vector que es ortogonal
abella recuerda que en el vídeo pasado
estábamos hablando acerca de cómo
encontrar la ecuación de un plano dado
un punto y un vector bueno pues sí ahora
tenemos dos vectores entonces ya podemos
encontrar la ecuación de un plano porque
si nosotros tenemos dos vectores que va
a pasar
-sector es bueno si los dos vectores no
son co lineales así que voy a dibujar
para cada vez este es am este de acá se
ven ojo estoy pidiendo que los dos
vectores no sean con lineales entonces
el espacio vectorial generado por dos
vectores es es un plano entonces déjeme
poner aquí al tanto que nos va a quedar
de nuestro espacio vectorial generado
por estos dos vectores es todo este de
aquí y a continuación lo que nos vamos a
dar cuenta es que a cruz b es decir el
producto cruz de dos vectores me va a
quedar un vector que es ortogonal a
estos dos o es ortogonal al plano por lo
tanto éste va a ser a cruz ven y
seguramente te estás preguntando por qué
me estoy tomando a éste como a cruz ven
porque no estoy tomando cualquier otro
vector o puede ser tal vez un vector que
sea para arriba ahorita vamos a hablar
de las magnitudes de la cruz pero lo que
quiero que veas es que porque no me
estoy dibujando un vector que vaya hacia
abajo un vector que va hacia abajo
también es ortogonal y bueno la
respuesta de esto es que estoy
utilizando la regla de la mano derecha y
como es la regla de la mano derecha
bueno déjenme intentar dibujar una mano
derecha por aquí
vas a decir que qué ocurrencias me saco
y qué bizarro pero esto que estoy
dibujando aquí voy a suponer que es mi
mano derecha este es mi dedo índice mi
dedo índice va a apuntar siempre a dónde
apunta el vector a entonces este dedo
índice que estoy dibujando aquí va a
apuntar hacia dónde va el vector y
después tengo que poner al vector b y
para eso voy a utilizar a mi dedo del
medio mi dedo de enmedio va a apuntar a
dónde está el vector b y los demás dedos
pues no hacen nada y mi pulgar me va a
decir a dónde va a cruz ven cuando yo
alzo mi pulgar mi pulgar me va a decir
dónde va a cruz ven y si podemos decir
que eres anatómicamente similar a mí
bueno realmente entonces este es el
vector am aquí lo voy a dibujar aquí
también me voy a tomar al vector ven y
entonces estoy diciendo que a cruce
siempre va a apuntar hacia arriba o
hacia donde vaya mi pulgar en mi mano
derecha tu pulgar no está colgando aquí
abajo por lo tanto creo que si puede
funcionar bastante la regla de la mano
derecha para pensar en nada cruz ve y
bueno ya que estamos en el contexto de
platicarles acerca de los vectores
ortogonales
la definición de un vector ortogonal a
otro que tenían que cumplir pues déjame
ponerlo aquí abajo si dos vectores eran
ortogonales entonces pasaba lo siguiente
estás de acuerdo ortogonales estamos
diciendo que a y b son ortogonales si
pasaba lo siguiente a punto b es igual a
0 recuerdas si pasaba esto es que eran
ortogonales y el producto punto de dos
vectores es igual a cero cumplan que es
ortogonales entonces yo estoy diciendo
que a cruces ortogonal a y también es
ortogonal a b entonces quiere decir que
su producto punto tiene que ser igual a
cero y bueno eso es lo que cumplían dos
vectores que eran ortogonales ahora
déjame mostrarte que en efecto a cruz b
es ortogonal tanto a como a b sería muy
bueno probarlo estás de acuerdo de hecho
creo que traería bastante satisfacción
probar esto así que me voy a poner un
poco por acá y la verdad no tengo ganas
de escribir otra vez a clave por lo
tanto lo voy a cortar ok cortar
y ahora lo voy a pegar entonces solo
quiero pegar pegar aquí y lo voy a
exponer por acá sé que está les quitarán
un poco de cosas raras pero bueno tú
entiendes que estos a cruz ven y ahora
lo que quiero hacer es el producto punto
de cruz ve con primero con la vamos a
ver ahora el vector a-1 a-2 a-3 y ahora
vamos a calcular el producto punto de la
cruz b por a y si esto me da 0 es que
son ortogonales así que vamos a
intentarlo
esto me queda a 1 que multiplica a la
primera componente de cruz b es decir a
1 x a 2 b 3 menos a 1 que va a
multiplicar a tres dedos y ya esto le
tengo que sumar recuerda como estaba
definido el producto punto eran sumas a
esto lo tengo que sumar a 2 que va a
multiplicar a la segunda componente de
este vector a cruz ven y me queda a dos
por tres por ver uno menos a dos por uno
ve tres y bueno ahora tengo que hacer lo
mismo que la tercer componente a tres
que va a multiplicar al tercer
componente de a cruz
y me queda a 3 que multiplica a 1 b 2 ya
esto le voy a quitar a 3 que multiplica
a 2 por 1 y yo sé que lo hice aquí abajo
tal vez te confunda un poco todo esto
pero date cuenta que al final estos dos
primeros términos que tengo aquí
salieron de multiplicar las dos primeras
componentes estos dos términos salieron
de multiplicar las segundas dos
componentes y por último estos otros dos
términos salieron de multiplicar las
terceras componentes y vamos a ver que
nos queda de todo esto me queda a uno a
dos de tres pero éste es positivo estás
de acuerdo y por acá tengo a dos a uno b
3 negativo y si el orden de los factores
no afecta el producto entonces este y
éste se cancelan bueno vamos a ver
nuestro siguiente sumando me quedan
menos a 1 a 3 b 2 y aquí tengo más a 3 a
1 b 2 se cancelan también changos y
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa con el
último sumando me queda a 2 a 3 b 1 y
aquí me queda menos 3 a 2 b 1 es lo
mismo por lo tanto también se cancelan y
qué creés si todos se van entonces el
producto punto de estos 2
al 0 o lo que quiere decir que a cruz ve
punto el vector a es igual a 0 y
entonces estos dos son vectores
ortogonales ahora voy a calcular lo
mismo para ver igual y para verlo son
ortogonales entonces voy a calcular a
cruz b punto b y lo voy a poner aquí
aquí voy a poner todo esto punto b pero
el vector b es el vector b1 b2 b3 así
que vamos a calcular cuánto es a cluj b
punto b y entonces me va a quedar de las
primeras componentes me queda b 1 que
multiplica a 2 b 3 - b 1 que va a
multiplicar a 3 b 2 b 1 que va a
multiplicar a 3 que a su vez va a
multiplicar a b2 y bueno ahora voy a
multiplicar las segundas componentes si
no queda b 2 que va a multiplicar a todo
esto de aquí b 2 que multiplica a 3 b 1
déjame ponerlo así esto me va a quedar
b2 b2 que va a multiplicar a este ya
éste es que si no luego me confundo y
recuerda que un errorcito y todo sale
mal entonces b 2 que multiplica a 3 b1
b2 que multiplica
13 ok y por último me voy a fijar en las
terceras componentes y las voy a
multiplicar también sumando me queda b 3
que multiplica a 1 v 2 - b 3 que
multiplica a a2 b1 y vamos a ver que se
cancela con que o si se cancela o si no
se cancela entonces hasta aquí creo que
vamos bien solamente utilizamos la
definición del producto punto y me queda
p 1a 2b 3 y aquí abajo me queda donde
está donde está aquí abajo me queda de 3
a 2 b 1 y entonces uno positivo y uno
negativo se van y me quedan menos de 1 a
3 b 2 y aquí tengo más b 3 b 1
está de 2 a 3 b uno positivo y uno
negativo y entonces también se cancelan
estos dos también se van y para
finalizar tengo uno negativo que es de 2
a 1 b 3 y 1 positivo que es b 3 a un 92
y por lo tanto estos dos también se
cancelan y esto quiere decir que el
producto punto de la cruz ve punto b me
da 0
o dicho de otra manera esto está genial
porque llegamos a lo que queríamos es
decir nos acabamos de dar cuenta que el
vector resultante de a cruz b es
ortogonal al vector b que al final es
justo lo que queríamos ver si a y b eran
ortogonales al vector a cruz b y bueno
espero que todo esto te ha sido bastante
útil porque lo vamos a utilizar en los
siguientes vídeos donde vamos a ver más
propiedades acerca del producto plus